[Applause]
happy friday everyone we made it it's
been a full week of nerdy news i'm here
to wrap it all up just for you exciting
news for sony and spider-man fans no
nothing new on andrew garfield's
potential return as a web slinger but
euphoria star sydney sweeney has been
cast alongside dakota johnson in the
upcoming madame webb feature film i have
never ever been happier i honestly hope
she is happy because this casting news
is rad i have more euphoria cast news
coming up but you have to wait till the
end of the video to hear that one
[Music]
all right we're moving on now to the
boys they released the trailer for
season three and it's a bloody good time
like literally i'm not really sure how
much of it we can show you because every
other second is someone exploding
[Music]
[Music]
so of course we're seeing some of the b
team soups that will play a big part in
this season soldier boy specifically
gets a lot of play and with the show
teasing him being even worse than
homelander
i'm a little scared we're also getting a
good look at what happens when the good
guys the boys try to even out the
playing field by taking compound v
yeah from that doesn't look like it's
going uh all too well now a detail from
the trailer that fans of the boys comics
will like black noir is back having
survived his nut allergy attack from
maeve in the season two finale but also
that character might be receiving a
shocking twist similar to that of the
comics now if you don't know the whole
story from the books this is a major
spoiler but if you're a fan i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna let you know
anyways people that read the comics know
that black noir is the main antagonist
in the books and actually a clone of
homelander who's used as a means to keep
homelander in check if he ever steps out
of line
[Music]
now the editing and the trailer
intentionally put certain images and
lyrics of imagine dragon's track bones
together to imply that we might finally
be getting that storyline i don't know
about you but i'm excited to see
homelander get a taste of his own soups
medicine i mean not more compound v
you know what i mean
thank you
excitement is building for oscar isaac
in moonlight which is just around the
corner marvel released this official
clip from the show that gives us a
close-up view of the egyptian moon god
konshu
[Music]
are you guys as hyped about this as i am
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
from the multiple personalities to the
mental health aspect and the ancient
gods and supernatural mcu characters
that could all make an appearance maybe
this escape from reality might be just
what we need as a prelude to the
multiple realities of dr strange and the
multiverse of madness and i for one am
here for all of it
every aspect of this show has a duality
and we've shifted the paradigm
and just when you thought we were done
with the beatdowns umbrella academy
teased fans at south by southwest for
the first look at season 3 which we are
calling umbrella academy versus the
sparrow academy and it looks like
something is about to go down when the
series returns to netflix on june 22. oh
and about that euphoria casting news for
fans of the show get ready for more
ashtray not specifically ashtray but the
new season of the umbrella academy will
feature an appearance by javon walton
who played fesco's younger brother in
the hbo hit team drama all right that's
it for me what are you excited to see
dropping soon is it the boys is it moon
night should we have more or less people
exploding on screen all the time i i
don't know you let me know as always
drop your comments down below and we'll
see you next time
you